- [Instructor] In chemistry
we're going to see situations
where a molecule, an entire
molecule itself might be neutral
but because of the differences
in electronegativities
and how the molecules are structured,
you might have a partially
positive charge on one side
and a partially negative
charge on another side.
And the most famous example
of that is a water molecule.
A water molecule, the
three-molecule water molecules
depicted here with the
white oxygen molecule
in the center and the two
hydrogens right over here.
And this is the shape
of the water molecules.
Sometimes you'll see it
with this electron pairs
on the other end from the oxygen
from those hydrogens.
But what's interesting
at least in the course
of this discussion about a water molecule
is even though the entire
molecule is neutral,
you have a total of 10 protons
and 10 electrons in total
even though it's neutral
because of this shape
and because the oxygen
is more electronegative,
you can end up with a
more positive charge on one end
and a more negative
charge on the other end.
And just to reinforce this,
we look at the periodic table
and we know in general as
we get all the top right,
we get more and more electronegative.
An oxygen is one of the
most electronegative
of the elements, it's a good
bit more electronegative
than hydrogen right over here.
So in this situation,
in this water molecule
the electrons and the covalent bond
between the hydrogen and the oxygen
are actually gonna spend more time
around the oxygen.
I could draw it something like this.
They're gonna spend more time around here
because oxygen likes to hug the electrons
more than the hydrogen does.
So what it would do is it form a,
you could say partial negative charge
at the side of the molecule
away from the hydrogens
and a partial positive charge on the sides
where the hydrogens are.
In this situation where
you have a separation
of positive and negative
charges within a molecule,
this is called a molecular dipole.
Let me write that down.
Molecular dipole.
And in a Physics class you
might study the general idea
of a dipole and this is an electric dipole
where you have a separation
of your positive and negative charges.
In this case we show the molecular dipole
because it's a course
across the short space
of an actual molecule.
This should not be confused
with a magnetic dipole
which we might also talk
about in other videos.
Now in a water molecule the
dipole is a permanent dipole.
Because we're not changing
electronegativities here,
the oxygen just likes to
hug those electrons more.
So this situation, let me write this,
this is a permanent dipole.
Because of this permanent
dipole mixes water molecules
that's what allows these water molecules
to be attracted to each other.
So this molecule right over here,
this end is going to
be partially negative,
this part and it's gonna
be partially positive.
This lower case delta here
is how we denote that partial charge.
Those look like eight
so let me write them a little bit neater.
So partially negative
and partially positive.
Right over here this would
be partially positive,
partially positive, partially negative.
Because of this permanent
dipole of the water molecules,
you can have attraction, the
partially negative chart sides
are gonna be attracted to the
partially positive charges.
These are the famous
hydrogen bonds of water.
So that is of H2O,
so that's going to be,
either most of the attraction
that you see over there.
Now all molecular dipoles
don't have to be permanent.
So here is a depiction of
some methane molecules.
Methane is CH4.
You see in methane that
the carbon is bonded
somewhat symmetrically, you
have this tetrahedral shape
where the hydrogens
are evenly distributed,
they're getting as far away
as they can from each other
so there's not, it's a very symmetrical
and three-dimensions shape.
Also carbon and hydrogen's
electronegativities
aren't that far apart.
Carbon is a little bit
more electronegative.
But because they are close
and there's this symmetry
to the actual molecule, there
isn't a permanent dipole
in this situation.
However, you have to
remember these electrons
that are buzzing around
between these bonds
and around the nuclei
of the different atoms,
they aren't just staying in one place.
At any given time you might have
some of the electrons more on this side
of this molecule.
So you'll have a temporary
partial negative charge there,
maybe a temporary partially
positive charge there.
And that might be the exact
same time that this molecule
right over here has, this
molecule right over here
maybe its electrons happened
to be more distributed more
in that direction so it's
partially negative there
and partially positive here.
So when you have just
these random dipoles form,
at just a certain moment in
time, just based on that moment
how the electrons are distributed,
we call that a temporary dipole.
Temporary dipole.
And those temporary dipoles
can create this temporary
forces between molecules.
We studied that in other videos,
the famous London dispersion forces.
Right at the moment that this
one is partially negative
and this one is partially positive,
maybe that's right at the
moment that this one is
partially negative at this side
and partially positive at this side.
So the electrons are spending
a little bit more time here
and so they might be
attracted to each other.
Not only could it just
be a temporary thing,
it could also be induced.
If this one just happens
to be in that state
and is partially positive on this side,
well, the electrons here on this molecule
will be naturally attracted
so it might be an induced dipole.
And you could have, to be more explicit
induced dipoles because
of an external force
of the environment like an electric field,
you could have an induced dipole.
Let's say you have a molecule
of H2O right over here
and let's say you have a
molecule of neutral methane
right over here.
And that neutral methane, it's
electrons are moving around
but it has no permanent dipole.
But as it gets near this water molecule,
right over here, well it
has a permanent dipole
where it has a positive charge here
so maybe the methane molecules electrons
might be attracted more
to that positive charge.
So this situation where you take something
that otherwise would only
maybe have temporary dipoles
but because it's electrons
might be attracted to something
or repelled from something.
Here you could have an induced,
you could have an induced dipole.
And dipoles actually don't
just happen to be with
multi atom molecules.
You can even have not permanent dipoles
but you could have induced
or temporary dipoles
from a single atom.
Let's say we were to
take an atom of argon.
The noble gases are famously non reactive.
So let's say that this
is one atom of argon.
Let's say that's its electron cloud.
Let's say that's its nucleus there
and this is a huge over simplification.
You could imagine at
just some random point
the electrons are just a
little bit more distributed
on that side.
So you have this temporary
dipole that would form
where you're more negative here
and more positive right over here.
Of course if this is next to something
they might be able to
interact with each other.
If this is, maybe you
can even induce this.
It might not be random,
it might be induced
by a polar molecule nearby,
something with a permanent dipole.
Or it might be induced
by a magnetic field.
I'll leave you there but this
idea of molecular dipoles
whether they're permanent,
induced or temporary,
it's a really neat idea
because it actually explains
a lot of the properties of molecules,
their boiling points,
their freezing points,
how hard it is to get them
to again to a gaseous state
versus a liquid versus a solid state.
And we'll see a lot of that in Chemistry.